I've been requested to do some problems
you do on critical points and maximum
minima and connectivity so I will do
some problems so these were sent to me
by Akash I don't know where he is but
these are interesting problems and I
haven't done anything like these before
so I thought I would do the exact
problems he's given so this the first
problem says identify the critical
points and find the maximum and minimum
value on the given interval and they say
f of X f of X is equal to x squared plus
4x plus 4 and the interval that they
care about is from minus 4 and including
minus 4 that so we have the brackets
there to 0 and just so you know this
interval notation if it was written like
this with parentheses it would mean all
the numbers between minus 4 and 0 but
not including them this means that we're
this is a closed interval so you're
including minus 4 and you're including 0
this is called an open interval anyway
you could ignore this because that's not
what was in the problem so the first
thing they ask is what are the critical
points and different people use
different terminology but my
understanding is critical points or all
the points that are interesting so it's
the point where the derivative is equal
to 0 or the derivative just doesn't
exist but as we see in this interval as
well 6 the derivative F prime of X is
equal to 2x plus 4 so when does this
equal to 0 let's see 2x plus 4 is equal
to 0 to X is equal to minus 4 right now
just almost made a mistake there X is
equal to minus 2 and when X is equal to
minus 2 what is so what is f of minus 2
F of minus so we know that F prime of
minus 2 is equal to 0 we just solved for
that so we know the slope is 0 at that
point but I just want to know what the
coordinate point is so f of minus 2 it's
4 minus 8 plus 4 F of minus 2 is 0 let's
evaluate the function at the end points
of this interval f of minus 4 is equal
to
- 4 squared is 16 - 16 right 4 times so
that's 0 and then plus 4 so f of minus 4
is 4 and then what's F of 0 F of 0 is
equal to well that's 0 0 let's equal to
4 so now we could we could graph this
let me graph a different so if this is
the x axis or the x axis that is the x
axis and that is the y axis and the
interval that we care about is from x is
equal to minus 4 from minus 4 to 0 so
the first thing they said we'll identify
the critical points well the critical
points were when the slope is equal to 0
and that's it f is equal to -2 and that
happens at the point minus 2 comma 0 so
it's right here which is directly in
between those two points incidentally
which is a good intuition behind why
these two values are equal because it's
a this is a parabola and it's symmetric
so if you go to a way on either side
your the function should have the same
value but anyway ignore that it confused
you so - do we have a negative slope f
of 0 is equal to 4 and f of minus 4 is
equal to 4 so the graph is going to look
something like this and I'll do it in
another color the graph and so it's
really care about that interval let's
only graph it over that interval it
looks something like that and if you
said this was a critical point and they
want to know the maxima in the minimum
point well the minimum point is pretty
clear it's this critical point right
here where the derivative was equal to 0
and if you wanted to use you know
whatever they call it the connectivity
theorem but hopefully you have the
intuition of why you would see that the
second derivative at this point is
positive right what's the second
derivative if that's f prime of X F
prime prime of X for all X is equal to 2
so really this thing is going to be at
any point you test you're going to get
the second derivative to be positive so
especially at this critical point with
first derivative is zero the second
derivative being positive tells you that
the slope is constantly increasing so
the rate of change of the slope is
positive right the slope is really
negative they're a little less negative
goes to zero and then keeps increasing
becomes more positive even more positive
slope there so I bet I think that was
out of the scope of this exact problem
but it's good to have that intuition and
then they want to know the maximum
points well the value here at X is equal
to minus four and the value of x equals
zero
they're both maximum points they're kind
of a tie for first place so those are
the maximum points 0 x equals 0 and x
equals minus 4 you could say 0 comma 4
or minus 4 comma 4 what's the next
problem they give let's see I find these
problems the understanding the problem
is often and the terminology is often
more confusing than the problem itself
so they give H of R is equal to 1 over R
and they care about the interval they
care about the interval I'm assuming
from 1 this is an interval on R from
negative 1 to 3 and we're going to
include negative 1 and 3 because we have
brackets well what are the critical
points they're the points where either
well either the the derivative is 0 or
the derivative doesn't exist now this is
this is this brings up an interesting
point right because well we'll see in a
second there's a point here where the
derivative doesn't exist but the
function also isn't defined at that
point so that's not a critical point so
in order to get a critical point and
this is a bit of a technicality critical
point the easy one is derivative is 0
derivative equals 0 the other critical
point it I was a little bit I was a
little bit non rigorous with it when I
when I said before is when there's no
derivative there's no derivative
derivative but f of X is defined
is defined so as you're going to see
this problem there is a point where the
derivative is undefined but f of X is or
in this case H of R is also not defined
at that point so it won't be a critical
point or maybe it is I don't know
depending on how your teacher defines it
but the way I learned it is a critical
point if the derivative isn't defined
but the function is but anyway well
what's the derivative here H prime of R
well that's R to the negative 1 right so
it becomes negative R to the negative 2
or that's minus 1 over R squared that's
the derivative this can this ever equal
0 well no it's never going to be equal 0
but where is it undefined well it's
undefined when R is equal to 0 and R
equal to 0 is in that interval right so
H prime of 0 is undefined but H of 0 is
also undefined right 1 over 0 is
undefined H of 0 also undefined so I'm
not going to really consider that to be
a critical point frankly it's it's just
a point at which the derivative and and
and and the function is undefined and so
what will the graph look like well let's
see if we can draw the draw the interval
we might just want to draw some points
that's what I always used to do if I
ever got stuck on a on a math problem I
would just drop grab some points you can
never go wrong with that see 1 over R so
we want to go from negative 1 to 3 so
we're going to some negative values so
we want to go from R this is the R axis
right because these function of R this
is the H of our axis so we're going to
go from R is equal to negative 1 to R is
equal to 3 R is equal to 3 and we could
plot some points what is H of negative 1
it's 1 over negative 1 so it's this
point right here
it's one over negative one and then what
happens is we get to smaller and smaller
negative numbers well think about it if
you have negative 1/2 here if when R is
negative 1/2 it goes to negative 2 and
it just keeps it actually it's actually
going to asymptote right if we only care
about this interval so it's going to
look something like this I'm going to
ask them to negative infinity right if I
kept drawing this all the way down that
would just asymptote and then what is H
of 3 well H of 3 is just going to be 1/3
it's going to be a relatively low number
and then what's going to happen is we
get closer and closer to 0 well if you
put a really small positive value here
you approach you get larger and larger
numbers right so this actually
asymptotes to positive infinity this
asymptotes to positive infinity so to
look something like this I always have
trouble drawing these hyperbolas it's
going to look something like that it's
going to go to positive infinity so that
goes to positive infinity and this will
on this side go to minus infinity and
frankly just looking at this graph you
see why the graph is not defined at 0
right they from from the right-hand side
the limit approaches positive infinity
from the left-hand side approaches
negative infinity and 1 over 0 is just
undefined and well similarly that's
that's why you know you couldn't get a
derivative there either because you know
that the definition of the derivative
means you're taking a limit and the
limit has to be valid from both
directions and as we see the limit is
not valid from both directions here so
what are the the maximum and minimum
points here well if we look at if we
look at this value we might say well is
that a minimum point well no because you
have values much lower actually you have
you have values that go to minus
infinity in this interval and then you
say well is this a maximum point well no
you have values that go to positive
infinity in this interval so it actually
turns out that there is no I guess you
could call I mean this this isn't very
proper but to some degree at 0 you're at
both positive and negative infinity
depending on you know what direction
you're coming from but this really has
no
maximum or minimum points because graph
is undefined at zero and then you know
for if I said oh well what if I get
really close to zero and I call that the
maximum point then you say no no no but
there's a point even closer that has
even a higher value that's even closer
to infinity so there is actually no
exact point that is the maximum value so
that's that's that's kind of interesting
anyway I'm already at 11 minutes and
people have at YouTube apparently lets
me go well past the limit now but people
have told me that they like the
10-minute nuggets of knowledge so I will
stop now and I'll continue these
problems in a future video see you soon